the self symbols of totality if an
individual has wrestled seriously enough
and long enough with the anima or animus
problem so that he or she is no longer
partially identified with it the
unconscious again changes its dominant
character and appears in a new symbolic
form representing the self the innermost
nucleus of the psyche in the dreams of a
woman this Center is usually personified
as a superior female figure a priestess
sorceress earth mother or goddess of
nature or love in the case of a man it
manifests itself as a masculine
initiator and guardian an Indian guru a
wise old man a spirit of nature and so
forth two folktales illustrate the role
that such a figure can play the first is
an Austrian tale a king has ordered
soldiers to keep the Night Watch beside
the corpse of a black princess who has
been bewitched every midnight she rises
and kills the guard at last one soldier
who was turned to did is to stand guard
despairs and runs away into the woods
there he meets an old guitarist who is
our Lord Himself this old musician tells
him where to hide in the church and
instruct him on how to behave so that
the black princess cannot get him with
this divine help the soldier actually
manages to redeem the princess and marry
her clearly the old guitarist who is our
Lord Himself is in psychological terms a
symbolic personification of the self
with his help the ego avoids destruction
and is able to overcome and even redeem
a highly dangerous aspect of his anima
in a woman's psyche as I have said the
self assumes feminine personifications
this is illustrated in the second story
an eskimo tale a lonely girl who has
been disappointed in love meets a wizard
traveling in a copper boat he is the
spirit of the moon who has given all the
animals to mankind and who also bestows
luck in hunting he abducts the girl to
the heavenly realm once when the spirit
of the moon has left her she visits a
little house near the moon
it's mansion there she finds a tiny
woman clothed in the intestinal membrane
of the bearded seal who warns the
heroine against the Spirit of the Moon
saying that he plans to kill her it
appears that he is a killer of women a
sort of Bluebeard the tiny woman
fashions a long rope by means of which
the girl can descend to earth at the
time of the new moon which is the moment
when the little woman can weaken the
moon spirit the girl climbs down but
when she arrives on earth she does not
open her eyes as quickly as the little
woman told her to because of this she
has turned into a spider and can never
become human again as we have noted the
divine musician in the first tale is a
representation of the wise old man a
typical personification of the self he
is akin to the sorcerer Merlin of
medieval legend or to the Greek god
Hermes the little woman in her strange
membrane clothing is a parallel figure
symbolizing the self as it appears in
the feminine psyche the old musician
saves the hero from the destructive
anima and the little woman protects the
girl against the eskimo Bluebeard who is
in the form of the moon spirit her
animus in this case however things go
wrong a point that I shall take up later
the self however does not always take
the form of a wise old man or wise old
woman these paradoxical personifications
are attempt to express something that is
not entirely contained in time something
simultaneously young and old the dream
of a middle-aged man shows the self
appearing as a young man coming from the
street a youth rode down into our garden
there were no bushes and no fence as
there are in real life and the garden
lay open I did not quite know if he came
on purpose or if the horse carried him
here against his will I stood on the
path that leads to my studio and watched
the arrival with great pleasure the
sight of the boy on his beautiful horse
impressed me deeply the horse was a
small wild powerful animal a symbol of
energy it resembled a boar and it had a
thick bristly silvery gray coat
boy rode past me between the studio and
house jumped off his horse and led him
carefully away so that he would not
trample on the flowerbed with its
beautiful red and orange tulips the
flowerbed had been newly made and
planted by my wife a dream occurrence
this youth signifies the self and with
it renewal of life a creative a la vita
and a new spiritual orientation by means
of which everything becomes full of life
and enterprise if a man devotes himself
to the instructions of his own
unconscious it can bestow this gift so
that suddenly life which has been stale
and dull turns into a rich unending
inner adventure full of creative
possibilities in a woman's psychology
this same youthful personification of
the self can appear as a supernaturally
gifted girl the dreamer in this instance
is a woman in her late 40s I stood in
front of a church and was washing the
pavement with water then I ran down the
street just at the moment when the
students from the high school were let
out I came to a stagnant River across
which a bore adore tree trunk had been
laid but when I was attempting to walk
across a mr. the student bounced on the
board so that it cracked and I nearly
fell into the water
idiot I yelled out on the other side of
the river three little girls were
playing and one of them stretched out
her hand as if to help me I thought that
her small hand was not strong enough to
help me but when I took it she succeeded
without the slightest effort in pulling
me across and up the bank on the other
side the dreamer is a religious person
but according to her dream she cannot
remain in the church Protestant any
longer in fact she seems to have lost
the possibility of entering it although
she tries to keep the access to it as
clean as she can according to the dream
she must now cross a stagnant river and
this indicates that the flow of life is
slowed down because of the unresolved
religious problem crossing a river is a
frequent symbolic image for a
fundamental change of attitude the
student was interpreted by the dreamer
herself as the personification of a
thought that she had previously had
namely that she might satisfy her spirit
earning by attending high school
obviously the dream does not think much
of this plan when she dares to cross the
river alone a personification of the
self the girl small but supernaturally
powerful helps her but the form of a
human being whether youthful or old is
only one of the many ways in which the
self can appear in dreams or visions the
various ages it assumes show not only
that it is with us throughout the whole
of life but also that it exists beyond
the consciously realized flow of life
which is what creates our experience of
time just as the self is not entirely
contained in our conscious experience of
time in our space-time dimension it is
also simultaneously omnipresent moreover
it appears frequently in a form that
hints at a special omnipresence that is
it manifests itself as a gigantic
symbolic human being who embraces and
contains the whole cosmos when this
image turns up in the dreams of an
individual we may hope for a creative
solution to his conflict because now the
vital psychic center is activated that
is the whole being is condensed into
oneness in order to overcome the
difficulty it is no wonder that this
figure of the cosmic man appears in many
myths and religious teachings generally
he is described as something helpful and
positive he appears as Adam as the
Persian guy Omar or as the Hindu Purusha
this figure may even be described as the
basic principle of the whole world
the ancient Chinese for instance thought
that before anything whatever was
created there was a colossal divine man
called pan qu who gave heaven and earth
their form when he cried his tears made
the Yellow River and the Yangtze River
when he breathed the wind rose when he
spoke Thunder was loosed and when he
looked around lightning flashed if he
was in a good mood the weather was fine
if he was sad it clouded over when he
died he fell apart and from his body the
five holy mountains of China sprang into
existence his head became the time out'n
in the east his trunk became the Sun
Mountain
Center his right arm the hung Mountain
in the north his left arm the hung
mountain in the South and his feet the
wah Mountain in the West his eyes became
the Sun and Moon we have already seen
that symbolic structures that seem to
refer to the process of individuation
tend to be based on the motif of the
number-four such as the four functions
of consciousness or the four stages of
the anima or animus it reappears here in
the cosmic shape of pond kou only under
specific circumstances do other
combinations of numbers appear in the
psychic material the natural unhampered
manifestations of the center are
characterized by four folds that is to
say by having four divisions or some
other structure deriving from the
numerical series of four eight sixteen
and so on number sixteen plays a
particularly important role since it is
composed of four fours in our Western
civilization similar ideas of a cosmic
man have attached themselves to the
symbol of Adam the first man there is a
Jewish legend that when God created Adam
he first gathered red black white and
yellow dust from the four corners of the
world and thus Adam reached from one end
of the world to the other when he bent
down his head was in the east and his
feet in the West according to another
Jewish tradition the whole of mankind
was contained in Adam from the beginning
which meant the soul of everybody who
would ever be born the soul of Adam
therefore was like the wick of a lamp
composed of innumerable strands in this
symbol the idea of a total oneness of
all human existence beyond all
individual units is clearly expressed in
ancient Persia the same original first
man called Gallo Mart was depicted as a
huge figure emitting light when he died
every kind of metal sprang from his body
and from his soul came gold his semen
fell upon the earth and from it came the
first human couple in the form of to
rhubarb shrubs it is striking that the
Chinese pran qu was also depicted
covered by leaves like a plant perhaps
this is because the first man was
thought of as
a self grown living unit that just
existed without any animal impulse or
self-will among a group of people who
live on the banks of the Tigris Adam is
still at the present time worshipped as
the hidden super-soul or mystical
protective spirit of the entire human
race these people say that he came from
a date palm another repetition of the
plant motif in the East and in some
Gnostic circles in the West people soon
recognized that the cosmic man was more
an inner psychic image than a concrete
outer reality according to Hindu
tradition for instance he is something
that lives within the individual human
being and is the only part that is
immortal this inner great man redeems
the individual by leading him out of
creation and its sufferings back into
his original eternal sphere but he can
do this only if man recognizes him and
rises from his sleep in order to be led
in the symbolic myths of old India this
figure is known as the purusa a name
that simply means man or person the
purusa lives within the heart of every
individual and yet at the same time he
fills the entire cosmos according to the
testimony of many myths the cosmic man
is not only the beginning but also the
final goal of all life of the whole of
creation all serial nature means wheat
all treasure nature means gold all
generation means man says the medieval
sage Meister Eckhart and if one looks at
this from a psychological standpoint it
is certainly so the whole inner psychic
reality of each individual is ultimately
oriented toward this archetypal symbol
of the self in practical terms this
means that the existence of human beings
will never be satisfactorily explained
in terms of isolated instincts or
purposive mechanisms such as hunger
power sex survival perpetuation of the
species and so on that is man's main
purpose is not to eat drink etcetera but
to be human above and beyond these
drives our inner psychic reality serves
to manifest a living mystery that can be
expressed only by a symbol and for
it's expression the unconscious often
chooses the powerful image of the cosmic
man in our Western civilization the
cosmic man has been identified to a
great extent with Christ and in the East
with Krishna or with Buddha in the Old
Testament this same symbolic figure
turns up as the son of man and in later
Jewish mysticism is called Adam Kadmon
certain religious movements of late
antiquity simply called him anthropos
the Greek word for man like all symbols
this image points to an unknowable
secret to the ultimate unknown meaning
of human existence as we have noted
certain traditions assert that the
cosmic man is the goal of creation but
the achievement of this should not be
understood as a possible external
happening from the point of view of the
Hindu for example it is not so much that
the external world will one day dissolve
into the original great man but that the
egos extroverted orientation toward the
external world will disappear in order
to make way for the cosmic man this
happens when the ego merges into the
self the egos discursive flow of
representations which goes from one
thought to another and its desires which
run from one object to another calm down
when the great man within is encountered
indeed we must never forget that for us
outer reality exists only insofar as we
perceive it consciously and that we
cannot prove that it exists in and by
itself the many examples coming from
various civilizations and different
periods show the universality of the
symbol of the great man his image is
present in the minds of men as a sort of
goal or expression of the basic mystery
of our life because this symbol
represents that which is whole and
complete
it is often conceived of as a bisexual
being in this form the symbol reconciles
one of the most important pairs of
psychological opposites male and female
this union also appears frequently in
dreams as a divine royal or otherwise
distinguished couple the following dream
of a man of 47 shows this aspect of the
self in a dramatic
boy I am on a platform and below me I
see a huge black beautiful she-bear with
a rough but well-groomed coat she is
standing on her hind legs and on a stone
slab she is polishing a flat oval black
stone which becomes increasingly shiny
not far away a lioness and her cub do
the same thing but the stones they are
polishing are bigger and round in shape
after a while the she-bear turns into a
fat naked woman with black hair and dark
fiery eyes I behave in an erotic ly
provocative way toward her and suddenly
she moves nearer in order to catch me I
get frightened and take refuge upon the
building of scaffolding where I was
before later I am in the midst of many
women half of whom are primitive and
have rich black hair as if they are
transformed from animals the other half
are our women of the same nationality as
the dreamer and have blond or brown hair
the primitive women sing a very
sentimental song in melancholy
high-pitched voices now in a high
elegant carriage there comes a young man
who wears on his head a royal golden
crown set with shining rubies a very
beautiful sight beside him sits a blond
young woman probably his wife but
without a crown it seems that the
lioness and her cub have been
transformed into this couple they belong
to the group of primitives now all the
women the primitives and the others in
tone a solemn song and the royal
carriage slowly travels toward the
horizon here the inner nucleus of the
dreamers psyche shows itself at first in
a temporary vision of the royal couple
which emerges from the depths of his
animal nature and the primitive layer of
his unconscious the she-bear in the
beginning is a sort of mother goddess
Artemis for instance was worshipped in
Greece as a she-bear the dock oval stone
that she rubs and polishes probably
symbolizes the dreamers innermost being
his true personality rubbing and
polishing stones is a well-known
exceeding the ancient activity of man in
Europe holy stones wrapped in bark and
hidden in caves have been found in many
places as containers of divine powers
they were probably kept there by men of
the Stone Age at the present time some
of the Australian Aborigines believed
that their dead ancestors continued to
exist in stones as virtuous and divine
powers and that if they rub these stones
the power increases like charging them
with electricity for the benefit of both
the living and the dead
the man who had the dream we are
discussing had hitherto refused to
accept a marital bond with a woman his
fear of being caught by this aspect of
life caused him in the dream to flee
from the bear woman to the spectators
platform where he could passively watch
things without becoming entangled
through the motif of the stone being
rubbed by the bear the unconscious is
trying to show him that he should let
himself come into contact with this side
of life it is through the frictions of
married life that his inner being can be
shaped and polished when the stone is
polished it will begin to shine like a
mirror so that the bear can see herself
in it
this means that only by accepting
earthly contact and suffering can the
human soul be transformed into a mirror
in which the divine powers can perceive
themselves but the dreamer runs away to
a higher place that is into all sorts of
reflections by which he can escape the
demands of life the dream then shows him
that if he runs away from the demands of
life one part of his soul his anima will
remain undifferentiated a fact
symbolized by the group of nondescript
women that splits apart into a primitive
half and a more civilized one the
lioness and her son which then appear on
the scene personify the mysterious urge
toward individuation indicated by their
work at shaping the round stones a round
stone is a symbol of the self the Lions
a royal couple are in themselves a
symbol of totality in medieval symbolism
the philosopher's stone a preeminent
symbol of man's wholeness is represented
as a pair of lions or as a human couple
riding on lions symbolically this points
to the fact that often the urge toward
individuation appears in a veiled form
hidden in the over
passion one may feel for another person
in fact passion that goes beyond the
natural measure of love ultimately aims
at the mystery of becoming whole and
this is why one feels when one has
fallen passionately in love that
becoming one with the other person is
the only worthwhile goal of one's life
as long as the image of totality in this
dream expresses itself in the form of a
pair of lions it is still contained in
some such overwhelming passion but when
lion and lioness have turned into a king
and queen the urge to individuate has
reached the level of conscious
realization and can now be understood by
the ego as being the real goal of life
before the Lions had transformed
themselves into human beings it was only
the primitive women who sang and they
did so in the sentimental manner that is
to say the feelings of the dreamer
remained on a primitive and sentimental
level but in honor of the humanized
lions both the primitive and the
civilized women chatot common hymn of
praise their expression of their
feelings in a United form shows that the
inner split in the animal has now
changed into inner harmony
still another personification of the
self appears in a report of a woman's
so-called active imagination active
imagination is a certain way of
meditating imaginatively by which one
may deliberately enter into contact with
the unconscious and make a conscious
connection with psychic phenomena active
imagination is among the most important
of Jung's discoveries while it is in a
sense comparable to Eastern forms of
meditation such as the technique of Zen
Buddhism or of tantric yoga or to
Western techniques like those of the
Jesuit xog Thea it is fundamentally
different in that the meditator remains
completely devoid of any conscious goal
or program thus the meditation becomes
the solitary experiment of a free
individual which is the reverse of a
guided attempt to master the unconscious
this however is not the place to enter
into a detailed analysis of active
imagination the reader will find one of
Jung's descriptions of it in his paper
on the transcendent function in the
woman's meditation the self appeared as
a deer we
said to the ego I am your child and your
mother they call me the connecting
animal because I connect people animals
and even stones with one another if I
enter them
I am your fate or the objective I when I
appear I redeem you from the meaningless
hazards of life the fire burning inside
me burns in the whole of nature if a man
loses it he becomes egocentric lonely
disoriented and weak the self is often
symbolized as an animal representing our
instinctive nature and its connectedness
with one's surroundings that is why
there are so many helpful animals in
myths and fairy tales this relation of
the self to all surrounding nature and
even the cosmos probably comes from the
fact that the nuclear atom of our psyche
is somehow woven into the whole world
both outer and inner all the higher
manifestations of life are somehow tuned
to the surrounding space-time continuum
animals for example have their own
special foods their particular home
building materials and their definite
territories - all of which their
instinctive patterns are exactly tuned
and adapted time rhythms also play their
part we have only to think of the fact
that most grass eating animals have
their young at precisely the time of
year when the grass is richest and most
abundant with such considerations in
mind a well-known zoologist has said
that the inwardness of each animal
reaches far out into the world around it
and sacrifice time and space in ways
that are still completely beyond our
comprehension our unconscious is
similarly attuned to our surroundings to
our group to society in general and
beyond these two the space-time
continuum and the whole of nature thus
the great man of the Nazca be Indians
does not merely reveal inner truths he
also gives hints about where and when to
hunt and so from dreams the Nazca Peter
evolves the words and melodies of the
magical songs with which he attracts the
animals but this specific help from the
unconscious is not given to primitive
man alone young discovered that dreams
can also give civilized man the guy
he needs in finding his way through the
problems of both his inner and his outer
life indeed many of our dreams are
concerned with details of our outer life
and our surroundings such things as the
tree in front of the window one's
bicycle or car or a stone picked up
during a walk maybe raised to the level
of symbolism through our dream life and
become meaningful if we pay attention to
our dreams instead of living in a cold
impersonal world of meaningless chance
we may begin to emerge into a world of
our own full of important and secretly
ordered events our dreams however are
not as a rule primarily concerned with
our adaptation to outer life in our
civilized world most dreams have to do
with the development by the ego of the
right inner attitude toward the self for
this relationship is far more disturbed
in us by modern ways of thinking and
behaving than is the case with primitive
people they generally live directly from
the inner center but we with our
uprooted consciousness are so entangled
with external completely foreign matters
that it is very difficult for the
messages of the self to get through to
us our conscious mind continually
creates the illusion of a clearly shaped
real outer world that blocks off many
other perceptions yet through our
unconscious nature we are inexplicably
connected to our psychic and physical
environment I have already mentioned the
fact that the self is symbolized with
special frequency in the form of a stone
precious or otherwise we saw an example
of this in the stone that was being
polished by the she-bear and the Lions
in many dreams the nuclear center the
self also appears as a crystal the
mathematically precise arrangement of a
crystal evokes in us the intuitive
feeling that even in so-called dead
matter there is a spiritual ordering
principle at work
thus the crystal often symbolically
stands for the union of extreme
opposites of matter and spirit
perhaps crystals and stones are
especially apt symbols of the self
because of the just sonís of their
nature many people cannot refrain from
picking up stones of a slightly unusual
color or shape and keeping them without
knowing why they do this it is as if the
stones held a limb
mystery that fascinates them men had
collected stones since the beginning of
time and have apparently assumed that
certain ones were the containers of the
life force with all its mystery
the ancient Germans for instance
believed that the spirits of the dead
continued to live in their tombstones
the custom of placing stones on graves
may spring partly from the symbolic idea
that something eternal of the dead
person remains which can be most
fittingly represented by a stone for
while the human being is as different as
possible from a stone yet man's
innermost center is in a strange and
special way akin to it perhaps because
the stone symbolizes mere existence at
the farthest removed from the emotions
feelings fantasies and discursive
thinking of ego consciousness in this
sense the stone symbolizes what is
perhaps the simplest and deepest
experience the experience of something
eternal that man can have in those
moments when he feels immortal and
unalterable the urge that we find in
practically all civilizations to erect
stone monuments to famous men or on the
site of important events probably also
stems from this symbolic meaning of the
stone the stone that Jacob placed on the
spot where he had his famous dream or
certain stones left by simple people on
the tombs of local saints or heroes show
the original nature of the human urge to
express an otherwise inexpressible
experience by the stone symbol it is no
wonder that many religious cults use a
stone to signify God or to mark a place
of worship the holiest sanctuary of the
Islamic world as the Kaaba the black
stone in Mecca to which all pious
Muslims hope to make their pilgrimage
according to Christian ecclesiastical
symbolism Christ is the stone which the
builders rejected which became the head
of the corner Luke 2017 alternatively he
is called the spiritual rock from which
the water of life Springs first
Corinthians 10:4 medieval alchemists who
searched for the secret of matter in a
pre scientific way hoping to find God in
it or at least the working of divine
activity believe that this
secret was embodied in their famous
Philosopher's Stone but some of the
alchemists dimly perceived that they're
much sought-after stone was a symbol of
something that can be found only within
the psyche of man an old Arabian
alchemist mori Ennis said this thing the
Philosopher's Stone is extracted from
you you are its mineral and one can find
it in you or to put it more clearly they
the alchemists take it from you if you
recognize this the love and approbation
of the stone will grow within you know
that this is true without doubt the
alchemical stone the lapis symbolizes
something that can never be lost or
dissolved something eternal that some
alchemists compared to the mystical
experience of God within one's own soul
it usually takes prolonged suffering to
burn away all the superfluous psychic
elements concealing the stone but some
profound inner experience of the self
does occur to most people at least once
in a lifetime from the psychological
standpoint a genuinely religious
attitude consists of an effort to
discover this unique experience and
gradually to keep in tune with it it is
relevant that a stone is itself
something permanent so that the self
becomes an inner partner toward whom
one's attention is continually turned
the fact that this highest and most
frequent symbol of the self is an object
of lifeless matter points to yet another
field of inquiry in speculation that is
the still unknown relationship between
what we call the unconscious psyche and
what we call matter a mystery with which
psychosomatic medicine endeavors to
grapple in studying this still undefined
and unexplained connection it may prove
to be that psyche and matter are
actually the same phenomenon one
observed from within and the other from
without